[Music]
hey you guys let's talk about some more
books
now here's the thing that happened i
think maybe
on one of my last reviews hmm i can't
remember which one it was but i'm pretty
sure it was one that was about one of
the uh leisure books paperbacks that
came out like in the early 2000s i want
to say
and i think in the context of that i was
talking about it not being
super gross or like over the top gross
in the same way that xyz authors were
and i think one of the authors that i
brought up in that i don't want to call
it a tirade it wasn't that but one of
the authors that i brought up was
douglas clegg and i think i mentioned i
said oh i've got one of his books back
there thinking that it was like this
really gross uh you know kind of story
now this is another book that i read
before i read this back in 2003
somewhere around there and i want and i
remembered liking it so i was kind of
like okay well i want to do it again you
know read it again for this show like
i've been doing with some of the other
paperbacks that i had and then when i
was reading this i was like wait a
minute i'm pretty sure this is the book
that i was thinking of at all which
again i think is what happened when i
did um that book the rainy season the
one that i reviewed a few weeks ago i
think i had totally got that confused
with like some other book and i think i
got this one confused with some other
book too but i can't for the life of me
figure out what book i got it confused
with i don't know if it's another one
that i have or it was one that i checked
out of the library because like i said i
was reading a really really lot of
horror fiction i bought a lot of leisure
books uh you know paperbacks around this
time so it's very very possible that i
could have like mix some of them up with
one another and i'm pretty sure so it's
like it was funny i was like reading
this and it was like so i sort of
remembered it but then i was like this
is not the book that i was thinking
about at all and i don't even think it
was a douglas clegg book that i was
thinking about now that i'm thinking
about it but it was another one like a
leisure books one so this book is
nightmare house
now the interesting thing about this and
this was something that i didn't know
when i went back into rereading it and i
surely didn't know it the first time i
read it uh i only knew it when i was
like doing a little bit of research for
this show was that this book
is the first in a series i think it's
called the harrow house series because
like the name of the titular nightmare
house is actually called harrow
h-a-r-r-o-w yeah
and uh so yeah so but the weird thing
about it though at least according to
what i could determine
was that even though this was the first
one written i think it's copyrighted
1999 but this one didn't come out until
2003 but the weird thing about it is
that the second one in the series which
i'm not sure what it's called but the
second one in the series came out before
this one came out and then this one came
out later and i saw some reviews that
speculated that maybe uh because the
second one was kind of successful they
went back and like released this one
which had been written earlier um
because most people and i'd like i said
i can't really say but
um because i haven't read the second one
or any of the other ones in the series
because maybe most people said that like
the other ones in the series were really
good but this one not so much or this
one was like you know kind of a mixed
bag and i will agree with that too
because i kind of feel like it's weird
because the first time i read this i
remembered like really digging it like i
said when i thought about it later like
i was confusing it with another book
which i don't know why i did that i
guess because like i said i was reading
a lot of
leisure paperbacks around this time and
a lot of a handful of the same authors
at the same time and so i kind of like
mix some of the stories up but i
remember still liking this nonetheless
enough to be like oh yeah that was a
good one and i have to pull that
you know to review on the show
but this time around i didn't hate it
but
there was just something really really
disjointed about it i think that's like
the best word that i can come up with um
i actually liked the first half of it a
lot
but then once kind of supernatural stuff
started happening in earnest
it just it kind of lost me which is like
a weird thing to say
but i don't know it seemed like much
spookier like at first and then you know
when you were kind of just going into
the backstory of the house and like all
this other stuff but then once the
mystery got resolved i was just kind of
like man and and also i kind of felt
like the paranormal stuff was like
way over the top and it seemed like it
happened too quickly
um there was a lot of stuff that seemed
like it happened too quickly or didn't
have like enough development in this
maybe and i don't know if that's just
like the writing style
um like i said i thought that i had read
some other books of douglas clegg's i
thought i read the halloween man
but and i remember liking that but i now
i can't remember if i actually did read
it or not it was just like i said i've
read so much stuff you guys that i just
can't even remember because sometimes
i'll
i'll be like oh yeah i've been meaning
to read that and then i start reading
i'm like oh wait i already read this
book so i so i do that a lot um you know
it's because i can't remember everything
you know what i mean so basically what
the story of this is
it's set mostly in 1926 or like you know
the early you know 20th century let's
call it that
now our main character is a dude named
ethan gravesend although his real name
is esteban which
that kind of pl factors into like him
having this name and then his name being
different like later on
it's not like a huge deal but it does
kind of factor into it but we'll just
call it mccallum ethan because that's
you know what he's called throughout
most of the book
so ethan
i guess what ends up happening when he
was a kid uh and he kind of goes back
and forth with this
you know like flashbacks and stuff when
he was a kid he used to stay with his
grandfather sometimes at this really
like cool
mansion called harrow which i think is
in upstate new york so like in the
hudson valley or something like that now
his grandfather was like this really
eccentric dude
who
he was one of those guys that had so
much money he was kind of reclusive
and he was almost like a like a mrs
winchester type uh you know sarah
winchester type person where not so much
that he kept building onto the house but
well he kind of did he would have like
all these things brought over like from
europe so he would bring over like whole
entire buildings that he liked and he
had this whole
like ruined
cathedral type action like going on in
the backyard like he like he brought it
over from europe but he just built it
exactly the way like he didn't fix it up
he just made it look like a ruin or
whatever because he just liked the look
of it so much so he has this big
rambling old house
and like i said he's kind of reclusive
but he has like all this money
and i guess i don't know like a lot of
the townspeople i don't think they
there's kind of like a question about
how
much of a good guy he was the weird
thing about it is that like the
description on the back
i think the description on the back says
built by a madman which you know and i
know that like the blurb on the back of
the book generally isn't written by the
writer that's usually written by
somebody that's like you know wants
somebody to come across and go hey that
sounds good and like pick up and write
the book right so it's like marketing
people but i never got the sense as the
story unfolds that
ethan's grandfather his name was justin
gravesend uh was a madman there was some
ambiguity about it earlier like you
weren't really sure what he was up to in
there um and maybe some people thought
he was a little weird but he's not
really a met so that's a little bit of a
misnomer i guess a little bit not really
that big a deal but i'm just saying it
makes it sound a lot more dramatic than
it actually is
so he builds this house
and there's all kind of like rumors in
town about it and whatnot as there would
be about any kind of like reclusive rich
dude that built this bizarre mansion out
in the middle of nowhere
so he ends up dying
and his grandson ethan who is his only
living relative
ends up inheriting it so pretty much
near the beginning he's kind of going
out and like taking possession of the
house
now
along the way he kind of remembers very
fondly like being a kid there
and you know he all he remembers his
grandfather being a lovely person and
really the only person in his family
that he could relate to in any way
because his parents were like very
distant and you kind of find out why
later on i won't spoil like all the plot
points and stuff but um you find out
later on like why his parents like
treated him the way he treated him so he
was like he he um has very fond memories
of being at harrow as a child and he
also kind of has memories which you find
out later on um of the haunting around
the house because he says later on that
when he was a kid he used to see a
little girl like you know haunting the
house and all this other kind of stuff
so it's 1926 he's taking over the house
and so he moves in and immediately
there's kind of like a little bit of
friction
with there's she's kind of like the
servant housekeeper
person uh named wentworth who's one of
those real kind of like
busybody
moralistic uptight kind of chicks uh you
know kind of an old grandmotherly type
woman
and uh he doesn't really get along with
her all that much because you know he's
kind of
ethan is kind of like he was married but
his wife left him he's kind of like much
more into like he's like a modern guy or
at least you know modern in the in the
terms of the early 1920s and uh you know
she's very
moralistic and it's like you know these
people don't even go to church and all
this other kind of stuff so there's kind
of like some friction there and then
there's also this other kind of weird
young woman
who
is sort of like i guess she's like
another housekeeper like she's the other
one like on the shift or whatever um and
her name is maggie barrow
and she's kind of like
young and sort of foxy like you know
she's got red hair she's irish she's
very fiery and like take no [ __ ]
type of thing and there's like a lot of
people in the town think she's a witch
maybe because she acts she does kind of
weird [ __ ] like there's this great scene
actually like i said near the front of
the like the first half of the book is
actually really good like because it's
building up all this like mystery and
stuff where ethan actually meets maggie
he can't sleep one night or whatever and
he's kind of like wandering around in
the in the gardens and he sees her out
there and there's like all these feral
cats that's kind of another thing that
plays into it and there's all these
feral cats and she's out there like
picking
like picking stuff out of the garden or
whatever and it's like she looks like
it's like she almost looks like
this mystical type or whatever out there
and like that's kind of how they end up
meeting
and uh so yeah so that goes on and she
has a son
because i guess she you know she got
pregnant and like then the husband took
off and left her or whatever but she
kind of like i guess she sort of lives
on the grounds but not in the big house
because there's other houses like
outside the you know the thing for
servants and whatnot so she lives there
and a little bit of a romance starts to
develop between her and ethan although
again i think that's another thing that
happens like way too quickly it seems
like one of those things where
he's
basically like he just meets her and
then like a day or two later he's like
well i'm in love you know what i mean
it's just kind of like and it seems like
it hasn't been very long since his last
wife left him and it's just i don't know
it's just like everything kind of
happens like really quickly
so like i said the first half of the
book is actually kind of cool like
you're you're kind of building up this
mystery he's talking a little bit about
the history of the house like the kind
of the rumors around the house the
rumors that maybe his grandfather was
into spiritualism or
you know had invited all these kind of
like aleister crowley and like lizzie
borden and like people like that had
like been to the house because it had
all this mystical energy or whatever and
that maybe there was like some kind of
satanic cult going on or whatever and so
there's that kind of like build up
around it and that's like pretty cool
like ethan
kind of
remembering what it was like growing up
there and trying to square
you know his childhood memories of his
grandfather with some of the rumors that
were swirling around it but not
necessarily that he was a satanist but
that he had kind of all these
spiritualist people hanging out there
and it was like not entirely kosher so
there's that whole thing then right
about the halfway point of the book he's
like exploring the house
with maggie and her son
and
you know there's been like some haunting
[ __ ] happening like he's seen uh the
ghost a couple like he's seen like a
little girl a couple of times and as i
said he's not super surprised because he
was there as a kid and he so he knew
that the place was haunted because he'd
seen this little girl before so he's
seen her before and he's felt like all
these weird sensations um you know and
some of the uh manifestations are like
really big it's not just kind of like oh
i saw a little wispy shadow of a little
girl and heard giggling it's just kind
of like hey look the whole room like
looks like it's covered with ice and
like this crazy crazy [ __ ] and there's
like all kind of like crazy like
poltergeist activity type happening so
it's that so it's
it's funny because it's like the first
half of it seems very subdued but then
like when the paranormal [ __ ] starts
happening it's just like way the [ __ ]
over the top you know what i mean it's
just it's a very strange uh
juxtaposition
so yeah about the halfway point of the
book he's exploring the uh the house and
there's this room because maggie tells
him something about essentially your
grandfather built this house and there's
like a house inside another house or
there's like all these secret passages
and they're usually behind the mirrors
and stuff and so there's this one room
that he can't get into and it's like
there's a big thing about wentworth the
other servant like she says she doesn't
have the key and then you know so but
they finally find the key and they open
this door
i think it's like up in the attic or
somewhere and like the
like the doorway hasn't been like all
bricked up behind the door and then the
door is also locked there's like okay
well obviously something weird is going
on back here so they get a pickaxe or
whatever and they bust it open and in
there they find a body that's been in
there for a a while you know what i mean
it's not like fresh so at that point
they have to call in the you know little
town policeman whose name is pocket
and uh that's just that's his name he's
i guess that's his last name but that's
just what everybody calls him everybody
just calls him pocket so pocket comes to
the house and
basically there's at this point there's
like a huge exposition dump which
actually i think was probably my
favorite part of the book like where
pocket comes there
and he's basically like yeah i know who
this body is and i know like what all
the situation is so he just like
basically tells ethan
everything that happened from there it
seems like the danube of the of the book
like the the ending of it came like
really really quickly because what i had
forgotten about when i was reading this
was that see it looks like this long
right so i was like i was got to like
you know maybe this point here
and i was kind of like
okay well there's still like a lot left
and then i forgot that there's actually
another there's like a bonus
novella in the back of this called
purity which i'll also talk to in a
minute so actually the book ended like
way before i was expecting it to end
because i was thinking like it's going
on and on it's like they they figure out
like who this body is they figure out
this whole big secret about the house
there's like all this [ __ ] there's a
big [ __ ] egyptian tomb underneath in
the cellar and all this other kind of
stuff so they find all this stuff and
then i was just kind of like okay that's
pretty that's cool whatever and then
like the book just ended because like i
said there was all this stuff left and i
thought that the book was going to
continue but it didn't so it just like
ended really quick so i don't know if it
was just because i was expecting it to
be longer because i forgot that there
was another novella at the end but it
just seemed like it ended kind of
abruptly
which i thought was kind of odd but yeah
so like i said all together like the
first part of this
um the first part of this book i
actually really dig i liked all
the stuff about the history of the house
all the stuff about the spiritualists
and maybe maggie is a witch and maybe
this like it's just it was all very like
mysterious i like that it was set in the
1920s
and stuff like that so i kind of liked
all that about it i liked all the build
up and all the mystery and stuff but
then like once the ghostly [ __ ] started
happening and once you know the body got
found it just seemed like everything
just like happened like really quickly
like i said there's you know pocket
shows up to investigate the body being
behind the walls like you know
she'd been like walled in ethan's like
wait did my grandfather do that because
what the [ __ ] so you know and then and
then pocket comes in he's like no no i
know what the whole situation is then
like he tells him i'm all about it and
then from that point forward it just
seemed like the rest of the book was
them like uh investigate because
something bad happens with maggie and
then they end up having to like
investigate the house and finding all
this stuff in the cellar but it didn't
seem it seemed like it that needed more
time you know what i mean um i kind of
feel like ethan falling in love with
maggie that happened way too quickly
because like i said it's like they met
and then like a couple pages later he's
like oh my god i love her forever um
that was a little strange i just they do
that a lot of movies too it's like i
don't know it just seems really
unrealistic so there was that but i
don't know so so i kind of feel like the
pacing of it was a little bit strange
other than ethan who
was actually like a decent character but
the other characters you didn't really
get to spend enough time with them to to
really get any sense of them as people
you know and because like i said some of
them were just in a few scenes and then
it seemed like they were way more
important than i don't know so it seemed
like there was a lot of stuff that was
introduced you know about like the
spiritualist about this and that like
[ __ ] did happen and they did kind of
explain but i don't know like i said the
the word that would best describe at
least the second half would be a little
bit disjointed i just thought it was a
very disjointed type of story now like i
said i'm not gonna like cast aspersions
on the rest of his [ __ ] because from
what i can determine like at least from
the reviews is that this is part of a
series that went on like about this
house
and apparently like the next books in
the series are actually like really
really good and i think are even set in
like the modern day
whereas this one was set uh you know in
1926 now i'm not saying like because on
goodreads this does have like plenty of
like four and five rev star reviews i'm
not saying that but it did seem like the
you know the one and two star reviews
and some of the dnf reviews um were kind
of like they all had kind of the same
criticisms of it and i would and i can
kind of see where they're coming from i
didn't like i didn't get to a point
where i'm like oh i'm not going to
finish this or this sucks or whatever i
didn't get to that point but it did get
to a point like after it got to the
halfway point where i was just kind of
like i was just waiting to like get it
done and then and then it was just when
it finished i was just kind of like uh i
then i wasn't kind of ready to be
finished with it because i just thought
it wasn't developed enough i don't know
it's like it's it's kind of a
complicated thing to get across it's
just there were so many good ideas in
here and i just felt like they weren't
developed sufficiently that's all i'm
saying like a lot of stuff was like
brought up and then i just felt like it
wasn't
because it was a lot of stuff that was
brought up like i said there was the
whole spiritualist angle
you know there was the whole thing with
uh you know the woman walled up in the
thing there was the whole thing about
maybe the granddad and all there was
there was a lot of like
tendrils there that i feel like didn't
quite
that weren't quite developed all the way
it didn't quite connect in a way that
was satisfying at least to me i guess uh
is what i'm trying to say so like i said
it was not a great reading experience
the first half of it is definitely the
best part
but you know not not bad overall and
like i said i would totally um read some
of the others in the series because i do
like the idea behind this house and i do
like the concept of it i don't know so
maybe i can judge better like when i
read some of the other ones in the
series now
again what i was going to say actually
the novella that's at the end of this
like i said it's kind of like a bonus
novella it's about let me see i can't
remember how many pages it is it's about
it's about that long if you're like
looking at it and it's called purity
and it's interesting because i actually
liked i think i liked the novella better
than the actual better than the novel
itself
because this one purity was not
necessarily
i'm gonna say it's not necessarily
supernatural it was actually um just
about this guy
uh named owen who was a psychopath he
was a self-described psychopath
sociopath he lived on this island where
all of these people would like rich
people would come and vacation and he
i guess his dad was like a gardener on
this on these rich people's like
property or their estate or whatever so
he had grown up
being kind of in love with this dub with
the daughter of the family like the
really rich girl so it's kind of like
describes this one summer where she
comes back you know they're grown up now
and she comes back with another
boyfriend and he's like kind of plotting
how to get her get rid of the other guy
um and there's also like a lovecraftian
element too because he
worships dagon essentially um and he has
this little uh you know like a little
statue of him and [ __ ] like that so it's
but i liked that actually quite a bit
better even though i'm more of a fan of
haunted house stuff than straight ahead
like sociopath psychopath serial killer
type stuff but i don't know i just i
thought the novella was actually like
much better written i forgot to mention
this too but
the main book nightmare house one of the
oddest things about it this is a very
odd choice and i'm sure he did it on
purpose but
you know even though most of the book
was from ethan's point of view he was
like the main character
every now and then it would switch back
and forth from first person to third
person like sometimes in the same
chapter like a little go from one
section uh where he's talking like i did
this that and the other and then in the
next section he's like and then ethan
did this and that and he's like he kind
of explained why he did that but i don't
really know
i you know i i don't really know if it
was justified and
in a lot of ways it was just like really
confusing and it like kind of took me
out of the story like i get why he was
what he was going for
i suppose it just i don't know it was
like it was kind of jarring that he kept
like switching back and forth like that
so that was another thing that i forgot
to mention but yeah so like i said it's
worth reading if you like haunted house
stuff it's doing something a little bit
different like with the haunted house
thing not super different but i don't
know i kind of like the concept behind
it um and maybe like i said the other
books in the series
got better at least like the reviews uh
said that they did but yeah it just came
off as a little disjointed however i did
really like the novella at the end i
actually like that better than the
actual book so you know keep that in
mind if you uh want to read it and but
like i said i'm pretty sure i might have
read some other douglas clegg and liked
it so maybe this is just one of his
earlier ones i'm not really sure uh so
we'll we'll figure something out we'll
like we'll read some more in the series
and see how it turned out but yeah all
right so that'll do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys on the
next one bye